tras seis meses de investigaciones en la
comisión parlamentaria de investigación
vota definitivamente si el presidente
bolsonaro cometió crímenes premeditados
en la gestión de la pandemia su informe
recomienda imputarlo por diez cargos
entre los que figuran crímenes contra la
humanidad uso inadecuado de los fondos
públicos incitación al crimen y
prevaricación el borrador inicial
también incluía el genocidio contra
pueblos indígenas punto que al final se
excluyó de la causa que intenta
responsabilizar al mandatario por los
cientos de miles de muertes
pública que
presenta del pueblo que floyd allí el
presidente que se rió hoy fue el mismo
que dijo y que sobre las muertes por
kobe 19 el mismo presidente que dijo que
era una pequeña gripe nada más que eso
fue el mismo presidente que de manera
triste y macabras imitó a la gente sin
aire este macabro y mito
la investigación trata temas como la
falta de oxígeno manaos los retrasos en
la compra de vacunas y los discursos de
bolsonaro en contra de los
confinamientos además de su escepticismo
desde el inicio de la pandemia del cob y
19 y de que se resiste a asumir en
ninguna responsabilidad por la gestión
de la crisis sanitaria
pero nosotros sabemos que no tenemos la
culpa de absolutamente nada sabemos que
hicimos lo correcto desde el primer
momento
brasil suma más de 600.000 muertes por
el virus sólo por detrás de eeuu por lo
que ahora las víctimas piden
responsabilidades aunque nada garantiza
que la acusación prospere llega a la
justicia ya que primero tiene que pasar
por el fiscal general cercano a
bolsonaro